ma question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé de la prévention
Aurélien Rousseau monsieur le ministre
plus de 2 millions de femmes sont
atteintes d'endométriose en France
aujourd'hui oui 2 millions de femmes
dont le diagnostic est encore tardif
puisqu'il peut prendre jusqu'à 7 ans
l'enjeu est donc de mieux diagnostiquer
mieux accompagner et surtout soulager
celles qui souffrent au quotidien de
cette maladie comme vous le savez toutes
et tous un texte opportuniste arrive
dans un hémicycle on aurait préféré voir
leurs auteurs votez la loi visant à
améliorer les conditions de l'IVG votez
la résolution visant à reconnaître
l'endométriose comme une affection
longue durée en bref s'intéresser
réellement à la santé des femmes nous
majorité travaillons pour la santé des
femmes avec conviction et détermination
depuis 2017 nous nous associons bien
évidemment aux actions des différents
comités féminins pour le dépistage du
cancer du sein sur l'endométriose nous
écout sont les femmes et les
associations formidables qui les
accompagnent au quotidien que
disent-elles bien sûr la maladie revêt
plusieurs formes parfois invalidantes
mais ces femmes malades ne souhaitent en
rien être traité systématiquement de
victimes ou de personnes porteuses de
handicap ce qu'elle souhaite c'est que
le diagnostic soit facilité que le
parcours de soins soit adapté que les
acteurs concernés soient bien formés et
que la maladie soit mieux connue
monsieur le ministre pourriez-vous nous
faire un point d'étape sur la façon dont
vous comptez répondre aux besoins qui
expriment les femmes atteintes
d'endométriose et nous dresser un
premier bilan des actions mis en oeuvre
réellement au sein de la stratégie
nationale de lutte contre l'endométriose
je vous remercie merci beaucoup ma chère
collègue la parole est à moitié Aurélien
Rousseau ministre de la santé et de la
prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Véronique Riotton
l'endométriose est un problème de
société c'est un problème de santé
publique aujourd'hui une femme sur dix
en est atteint et cela nécessite une
réponse collective une réponse
collective qui n'a pas commencé il y a
quelques semaines mais qu'il y a
commencé il y a de nombreuses années
sous l'impulsion notamment des
associations à qui je veux rendre
hommage sous l'impulsion de
parlementaire dans cette assemblée à qui
je veux rendre hommage Véronique louvagi
Sébastien paye ta vie ou clémentinotin
par exemple et sous l'engagement du
gouvernement et de toute cette majorité
pour porter une stratégie nationale sur
l'endométriose ce sont des actes ce ne
sont pas des récupérations de la 25e
heure
et donc
demain matin
avec Sylvie Retailleau et avec Bérengère
Couillard nous présiderons à Rennes le
comité de pilotage de cette stratégie
sur les trois grands axes d'abord
toujours
toujours mieux faire connaître cette
maladie parce qu'aujourd'hui encore il y
a un certain qui considère que c'est une
maladie de bonne femme non
l'andométriose est un sujet de santé
publique deuxièmement faire progresser
la recherche pour que la France soit aux
avant-postes troisièmement toujours et
encore former les professionnels faire
reconnaître cette maladie pour mettre un
terme à l'errance diagnostique alors
nous devons aller encore plus loin j'ai
signé la semaine dernière une
instruction pour renforcer notamment
l'homogénéité des prises en charge en
affection de longue durée parce qu'elle
existe cette affection de longue durée
elle a triplé en 4 ans elle a été elle a
augmenté de 50% à 9 ans et encore une
fois je pense que c'est un sujet de
mobilisation collective plutôt que
d'appropriation de la dernière minute
merci
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]